approchons-nous de cette petite planète
qui a priori n'a rien d'extraordinaire
angle 05 390 nous glissons à la surface
de son sol gelé mais nous allons avoir
une surprise aussi plutôt glacée elle
est très loin de son étoile très froides
comme ça mais en plus elle est
malheureusement pour rien il y a pas de
vie sur une telle planète mais par
contre il doit y avoir un ciel
absolument super pourquoi pas la galaxie
la densité d'étoiles est beaucoup plus
grande un million de fois avoir plus
plus grande que dans notre voisinage
donc imaginons le ciel que l'on doit
avoir de vue depuis tel planète une
Myria d'étoiles 100 fois 1000 fois plus
de mots sur le ciel que ce qu'on a sur
terre malheureusement on pourra pas y
aller
alors bien sûr ce que cherche les
astronomes c'est une nouvelle terre mais
où donc la trouver on aimerait une
petite planète un peu comme la terre et
qui soit justement à la bonne distance
pour qu'il fasse ni trop chaud ni trop
froid église 580 D et la première petite
planète qui se trouve dans cette
situation c'est pas vraiment encore du
tout une planète comme la terre elle
fait 7 fois la masse la terre comme un
petit peu trop lourd comme ça mais elle
est dans la zone habitable de son étoile
Michel Mayer émet aujourd'hui une
hypothèse très personnelle surglise
581d une planète
océan pour Michel Mayer ce serait à
l'origine une planète glacée qui aurait
migré et fondu tout près de son étoile
et le résultat c'est un immense
océan rien à voir avec le signe
extrêmement faim que l'on connaît sur
terre mais réellement un océan peut-être
de 100 km de profondeur à présent voici
un objet incroyable PSR 12 57 plus 12
qui a une fantastique histoire cette
petite planète qui orbite autour d'un
pulsar un cadavre d'étoiles qui
tourbillonne en émettant un jet très
intense de rayons X et ultraviolet
elle fut détectée par hasard en 1990 par
l'instronome polonais 5 ans avant la
découverte officielle de Michel Mayor
mais à cette époque les astronomes
n'étaient pas certains qui pouvaient
s'agir d'une véritable planète mais on
avait tort c'était la première
exoplanète jamais découverte
le Corot elle vient de trouver
les planètes connues à ce jour Koro 7b à
peine plus grosse que la Terre elle
tourne en moins de 24 heures autour de
son étoile
B ici elle avait des habitants l'année
durait mois d'un jour ça ressemble à
l'histoire du Petit Prince alors du coup
puisqu'elle tourne en moins d'un jour
elle est très très proche de son étoile
elle est très proche du feu donc il y
fait très très chaud mais comme elle
regarde toujours le même côté l'étoile
comme la lune regarde toujours le même
côté de la terre et bien d'un côté elle
est très chaude et de l'autre elle est
probablement très froide donc si on doit
passer d'un côté à l'autre il faut
passer de son maillot de bain à sa
combinaison de ski